Speaker 1: All right, let's get into some
of your emails for the week if you want to
send an
Speaker 5: email and maybe have it featured
in the weekly e-mail bag.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
Please be aware I can't believe I still have
to make this admonishment.
Speaker 2: If you start
Speaker 5: emailing multiple times a day and
there are now like 30 or 40 people doing it,
your emails are being auto filtered into the
trash.
We just can't have this stuffed email box.
It's not what it's for.
We are not, you know, some people are sending
us just 30 news stories a day.
It's not an appropriate use of the email box.
You might as well stop.
We're not seeing your emails, but for other
people, invite David Pakman dot com if you're
going to reasonably use that.
We love hearing from you.
Let's get right into this week's email back
bag of first email is from Jay Baer, who says
Why do you avoid race and IQ?
Are you afraid of the truth?
We've gotten emails like this before.
Jay Baer writes.
You seem quite scared, David of the truth.
The link between race and IQ is as clear as
day.
Stefan Molyneux and Lauren Southern have discussed
in length about this before, and they aren't
racists.
Jews actually have a higher IQ than others,
and you probably realize this, but you can't
say it.
Don't be so afraid of reporting the truth.
Speaker 2: Listen to
Speaker 5: Charles
Speaker 2: Murray, Dr.
Speaker 5: David Duke and Stefon Mullin, you.
Speaker 1: Every time I get one of these,
Speaker 2: I always have to do a two
Speaker 5: part response.
First of all, why are you so obsessed with
this topic with all of the things going on
in the world?
Why would
Speaker 2: someone continually
Speaker 5: be fixated on this topic?
But most importantly, it's not a subject that
I've avoided avoided.
We have a long form.
VIDEO The truth about race and IQ?
Go watch it.
And that's all I have to say on the matter
now.
The problem is people see the video and then
they say, Well, but David, I don't agree with
your conclusions.
You need to do another video.
Speaker 2: These folks won't
Speaker 5: be happy until I just agree with
them.
And that's a very different request that they're
making.
We've talked about it.
It's not an interesting topic to me.
We've said everything we want to say about
it, and that's it.
Kyle wrote in Kyle from South Florida
Speaker 2: about
Speaker 5: Chris Cuomo and says in Chris Cuomo's
defense.
David, I was listening to you.
Take yesterday on the situation regarding
Chris Cuomo suspension from CNN.
I agree with you for the most part.
Him using his connections to help his brother
during a scandal
Speaker 2: is totally
Speaker 5: inappropriate and is absolutely
a violation of journalistic integrity.
However, I did not find it necessary to warrant
a suspension in Cuomo's defense.
He is the most watched hour of CNN as it and
is an influential voice on the left.
Why should he be suspended?
When journalists on right wing propaganda
networks resume business as usual, making
wildly false claims and peddling dangerous
conspiracies conspiracy theories, as a progressive,
I'm getting tired of holding ourselves to
a certain moral standard like journalistic
integrity while the right through that out
of the window a long time ago.
I'm not saying we should ever stoop to their
level, but I am saying we may want to reevaluate
who and what we should be condemning people
for.
Chris Cuomo suspension is unnecessary.
Not since this email.
It actually became a firing.
I disagree with this.
This is like when when Keith Olbermann
Speaker 2: violated policy
Speaker 5: by making some political donations,
when he was working at MSNBC and he was, was
he suspended and then fired or just fired?
He was punished for it.
A whole bunch of people said, Look at Fox
News.
The entire network is politically biased.
People who are participating in fundraisers
for candidates and doing all this stuff.
So nothing should happen to Keith Olbermann.
I reject that.
Once we say we don't need to hold ourselves
to sensible standards because they aren't
doing it, I think in some sense we become
as bad as them.
Now I've said before, there are cases where
we just need to play the game, for example,
gerrymandering.
The way that the Republican Party has gerrymandered,
manipulated congressional districts to their
advantage is disgusting.
It shouldn't be allowed, but it is, and the
left has no choice but to do the same any
time they have the opportunity until such
time that we have a different way of drawing
districts.
But you're going to just keep losing if you
don't do that.
But you work to change the rules here.
What Chris Cuomo did is completely
Speaker 2: inappropriate, and the punishment
Speaker 5: has to fit the actions not well.
What does or what would Fox News do?
So I think, Kyle, I appreciate the message.
We just have a difference of opinion, and
that's OK.
But I think that Chris Cuomo suspension was
completely approved.
Next email called Fake News, you are
Speaker 1: correct, in fact, that Trump didn't
invent
Speaker 5: the term fake news, actually, it
was one of Hitler's favorite terms.
Of course, he said.
Look, the press, I have observed it on many
Trump supporters, probably neo-Nazis.
I froze the first time I heard it in our language
in twenty sixteen before the election.
I believe I saw his ultimate intention.
Then, apparently, according to his first wife,
he read Hitler.
It's called my new order.
And that alone is a little chilling.
So, yeah, our so-called Patriot MAGA crowd
somehow doesn't realize it's a fascist term
used by an evil man who proved his evil one
hundred times over.
Yeah, I mean, listen, you're not wrong.
Even more recently, the term fake news within
the United States had a particular meaning,
and it was like, you know, the National Enquirer,
Hillary Clinton giving birth to an alien baby.
That's what we meant by fake news.
Speaker 2: Donald Trump has just
Speaker 5: completely changed
Speaker 2: what it
Speaker 5: means into any reporting critical
of me or things that I've done and
Speaker 2: said.
Speaker 5: And obviously, that is a perversion
of what fake news has always
Speaker 2: has always meant.
Speaker 5: Next is a tweet.
This was a tweet I got.
I pointed out, You know this.
This is actually a bigger story.
Back when it was Hillary Clinton versus Donald
Trump in 2016, there were some people on the
left saying, the Supreme Court, I don't care
about the Supreme Court.
Hillary and Trump are the same.
I don't care.
I'm not voting or I'm writing someone in or
whatever.
Donald Trump got three Supreme Court picks
Neil Gorsuch, Brett Kavanaugh and Amy Coney
Barrett.
And now, as a result of that, Roe v. Wade
may be undone in the United States.
We're not going to
Speaker 2: know until June.
Speaker 5: And so I tweeted, if Hillary had
won, Roe v. Wade wouldn't be on the chopping
block now.
A few people wrote back and said things like,
well, she said she would be open to compromise
on Roe v. Wade.
Wasn't that something?
She said she wasn't going to put in three
anti-abortion Supreme Court justices, OK?
A user on Twitter wrote back and said if Hillary
had
Speaker 2: won, we'd be in
Speaker 5: two wars and that is just such
a boring, tired narrative.
It is the Hillary stuff.
And we talked about this Monday in the context
of Joe Biden dramatically scaling back the
drone war after,
Speaker 2: quite frankly,
Speaker 5: decades of pushing this neocon
warmongering stuff.
Trump came in and said, Oh, the Iraq war was
bad, even though he said it was good when
he was interviewed by Howard Stern way back
when.
Speaker 2: And said,
Speaker 5: I'm not going to get us into wars
and
Speaker 2: Hillary will.
Speaker 5: And many Trumpists and Republicans
fell for it.
Hook, line and sinker.
Hillary Clinton was not going to get us into
two wars.
Is it possible that she would have engaged
in some kind of military conflicts, airstrikes,
whatever?
Absolutely most presidents do?
Trump did.
Obama did.
Bush, George VIDEO Yes, but this entire Hillary
was bloodthirsty and looking to start wars
everywhere.
It simply was not based in any evidence.
And by the way, they've been saying the same
thing about Joe Biden.
We're not closer to any war under Joe Biden.
If he starts one, we will talk about it, believe
me.
But it's just a made up and concocted narrative
that a lot of people fell for.
And if you actually ask them, what evidence
do you have that Hillary wanted to start two
wars?
See what happens?
See what they say to you?
Speaker 2: OK.
Speaker 5: Next email
Speaker 2: this one comes
Speaker 5: to us is actually a Facebook message.
You are a piece of s. Trump is the best president
in my lifetime.
Fifty three years.
Trump had America independent on oil.
Not true.
Unemployment at all time low.
Yes, unemployment was low.
That's absolutely true.
And unemployment is also really, really low
under Joe Biden.
They're not giving Joe Biden any credit for
that future jog outlook.
I guess they mean job outlook highest ever.
And China economy in shambles.
That's not true.
And of course, the tariffs on China were really
damaging to American companies.
And then after getting an automatic response
saying that I can't respond to these messages
individually, the same person wrote back and
said, Drop dead.
Liberal pukes.
This is what we're up against, guys.
Another Facebook message.
Are you kidding me?
Trump was the only president that put our
country first and the American people first.
If you like living in communist country, move
out.
Speaker 2: I am not a communist.
I'm not looking
Speaker 5: to live in a communist country.
I'm not looking for the United States to become
a communist country.
Speaker 2: The continued
Speaker 5: ignorance around
Speaker 2: what communism
Speaker 5: is is plaguing us like a virus
for lack of a better term, Bernard
Speaker 2: wrote in.
Speaker 5: Bernard writes, David, I love your
show.
Bond offers theory of stupidity on YouTube,
channel sprouts goes into what is happening
in America right now and the danger of America
losing democracy.
Hope this helps.
Yeah, I actually recently read a very good
article on Bon Hoffa's theory of stupidity,
and the main point of that is stupidity is
a more dangerous enemy of the good than evil.
And there's a number of different ways in
which you can make that case.
I am very sympathetic to that idea.
And part of what makes stupidity a more dangerous
enemy than evil is that stupidity lends itself
to manipulation in a very particular way.
That, as we saw, quite frankly under Trump,
lends itself to getting people to believe
and support absurd things, not because they
actually like them, but because they don't
even understand that they've been tricked.
They've been bamboozled.
And I think there's a really good if you search
Google for Bon Hoffa's theory of stupidity,
there's a medium article that explains it
in some pretty good detail.
That's worth reading.
John wrote in and says, Where did Trump's
oratory skills come from, David?
Regardless of your or my feelings on his character
or policies, you have to admit that Trump
is a skilled public speaker.
Although he has his malfunction, malfunctions
United shame and finding the oranges to name
a few.
He never ums or errs and can easily hold the
crowd's attention for an extended time.
My question is where did these skills come
from?
I don't think he had any formal training or
would have a chance to exercise them locked
up in that tower of his.
What do you think?
Yeah.
You know, I mean, here's the thing, John.
In a sense, you're right, John Trump was able
early on to generate interest.
His speeches were kind of wacky and entertaining,
in a sense.
His press briefings were certainly more lively
than those that Joe Biden has done.
But at the same time, a lot of times Trump's
rally crowds were completely bored.
Remember, for a while when Trump would come
out with papers, with polling on them, and
he would start reading polls and the crowd
was totally checked out.
Recently, he's done like hour and a half hour.
Forty five minute rallies a few months ago,
and the crowd is totally tuned out.
So I do agree that Trump has something that
makes him entertaining to some in a superficial
way.
But he also often loses the crowd in a very
immediate and kind of jarring way.
So I don't
Speaker 2: know
Speaker 5: even myself.
While, as you say, I don't like the guy's
policy positions or anything
Speaker 2: else, I did
Speaker 5: find myself entertained by some
of his events.
But recently, the endless sort of like Castro
type rallies where he's just going on and
on and on about nothing.
It's not really entertaining, and a lot of
people start walking out, so I think it's
a mix.
And Trump fundamentally is an entertainer,
so it shouldn't shock us that he has some
tools to entertain on a superficial level.
And obviously, you and I agree for the country,
it's not a good thing at all.
We have a great bonus show
Speaker 2: for you today.
Speaker 5: Sign up!
Join Pacman dot com.
You'll get instant access to the bonus show,
as well as our commercial free audio feeds
and commercial free video feeds for members
only.
Speaker 1: Sign up it!
Join Pacman dot com.
You can use the coupon
Unidentified: code better when you want to
get a discount.